you
[Music]
okay hi everyone thank you for coming
we have Natasha crooks with us today
Natasha is from Cornell and UT and many
other places including Paris and England
she is going to talk to us about her
work on transactional storage systems
and the first time I met Natasha we are
now the founding members of the OSD I
distributed transactions fan club which
is how she ran into me and Adriano while
we were talking about how much we love
distributed transactions and so this is
very much keeping in in line with what I
know about Natasha so yeah thanks a lot
yeah so I'm really happy to do it yeah
as Irene said I'm a PhD student at Texas
and a visiting student Cornell so my
Texas PhD mostly consists of me
shoveling snow but what I'm gonna try
and do today is using my research in
distributed systems and databases is to
try and convince you that placing
applications at the center of how reason
about systems is key to improving both
the performance and the semantics of
transactional data stores and what I
mean by transactional data stores are
key value stores or databases that
support transactions so I guess the
first question that I should answer is
why should you care about transactional
data stores in the first place
well you should care because they're the
software that allow applications to
store data and data is everywhere
medical records are being placed online
for better improve interoperability
factories are placing sensors on machine
parts to predict when they have to be
replaced and even your local Baker is at
it and it's tracking customer food
purchases to minimize food wastage so
what's interesting coyotes would I find
interesting is that the people designing
these applications are usually highly
trained domain experts but they're not
necessarily computer scientists it may
come as a surprise to you but your local
Baker probably does not know much about
distributed systems or Paxos but in that
ecosystem applications need software
solutions to store that data so this is
where the magic or the promise of the
cloud comes in the cloud basically
promises simplicity it offers managed
solutions to collect and store data
they require little technical expertise
and the way that I like to think about
cloud storage systems is that they
provide the abstraction of a failure
free black books they were scale as much
as one's wallet will allow in that
ecosystem applications usually interact
with a front-end that acts as a valve
shielding applications for the
complexity of distribution and
scalability now this all probably seems
fairly obvious to you but the point I
want to highlight here is that because
of this valve applications only interact
with the state of the system through the
reason they execute and well generally
the fact that the cloud is a black box
from the perspective of the application
means the applications can only observe
the external state of the system not any
of a system internals and that has a
number of consequences both positive and
negative so the one hand it introduces
new challenges the correctness
guarantees of data stores in are defined
correctness precisely later are usually
defined in terms of low-level constructs
like operation ordering or time stamps
there are no longer visible to
applications in this black box model on
the other not observing the internal
state of the system actually brings
opportunities specifically it offers
additional flexibility for
implementation and this is because the
state of individual component in the
data stores no longer needs to be
correct as long as the external state
appears correct or PES indistinguishable
from a state that is correct to
applications so to prove addressee
challenges and society's opportunities
would have argued over the course of my
PhD is that one should take a client
centric view to system development and
what I mean by client centric is this
correctness guarantees today are
currently expressed bottom-up starting
from the systems that implement these
guarantees instead I think they should
be implemented top-down starting from
the applications that observe these
guarantees and while taking a client
centric shift might seem like a fairly
minor so a Klein centric approach might
seem like a fairly minor shift it
actually brings several significant
benefits first is what allow my
co-authors invited to reformulate
correctness guarantees cleanly and
succinctly it's what allowed us to
improve the performance and the
semantics of conflict handling and call
consistency which is a popular
correctness guarantee and finally and
this was maybe the most surprising to me
it's what allowed us to design the first
system to support private sizeable
transactions with reasonable overhead so
what I'm going to do in the rest of this
talk is to try and share with you so my
enthusiasm for this approach and to do
so I'm going to first focus on how this
approach can improve our understanding
of correctness in transactional data
stores and then I'll didn't discuss some
of those surprising security benefit the
dis approach enables so not sure what
I'm going to try and convince your first
is the correctness definitions today our
client centric system centric sorry
they rely on properties like version
ordering or timestamps they're not
visible to applications instead I think
that a better way to express correctness
guarantees is to express characters
guarantees in terms of the states the
clients directly observe and I'm
hopefully going to convince you that
this makes it easier to compare and
relate different correctness guarantees
so like I said in this time I talked my
work specifically targets are
transactional data stores so before I
begin I just want to briefly specify
what I mean by a transaction so
transaction is a grouping of operations
that take effect atomically so either
all of the effects take all the actions
take effect or non do now just to
clarify notation if you look at the
example in the slide you have a
transaction the reads object X and
writes object Y just to clarify notation
s and C here denote respectively the
start and the end of the transaction and
y1 here refers to the first version of
object Y so in general transactions are
pretty nice they're a popular feature of
most database systems as they
significantly simplify program
development because they allow
developers to access multiple objects as
a single atomic unit correctness then in
the context of transactions usually
refers to a notion called isolation now
for performance modern databases usually
allow transactions to execute
concurrently so isolation then defines a
contract that regulates the interaction
between concurrently executing
transactions and the gold standard for
isolation in in database systems is a
notion called Sarai's ability now what
Sarah's ability says is that even though
transaction
might be executing concurrently for
performance the overall execution should
remain equivalent to an execution in
which all transactions are executing one
at a time so if you look at the example
on the slide here you have two
transactions t1 in blue and t2 in red
now t1 writes object x and y and T 2
reads T ones right now this execution is
Sarai's Abul as it can be reordered so
the t1 executes fully before t2 and in
general sir eyes ability is appealing as
it provides up the applications with the
illusion that they're executing an
isolation without concurrency
unfortunately it's also expensive as a
requires extensive coordination between
concurrently executing transactions and
rarely scales under heavy contention so
because of these performance concerns
many databases actually relax the
isolation guarantee that they provide to
application this is something called
weak isolation and for those of you who
know my adviser he really likes
motorcycles and I tend to think of weak
isolation in much the same way so on the
one hand isolation guarantees weak
isolation guarantees are fast
they rely on they relaxed the amount of
coordination between concurrently
executing transactions which allows for
better scalability and performance the
other way to say it is that they are
allow more transactions to execute
concurrently which improves throughput
the flipside is that they're dangerous
they're very tricky to reason about
because they allow for non sizeable
behaviors that can break application
logic so they make the programming
overhead significantly harder and so
these notions of anomalies which are non
Sarai's abour behaviors arm can be quite
complex so just to give you an intuition
for what they look like I'm going to run
through the example of something called
rights queue which is one of the most
well known types of anomalies and rights
you can brake application invariants so
to illustrate let's consider Allison Bob
the share a checking and savings account
and can read or money from either as
long as the joint balance is not
negative and let's assume that they both
try to read through 50 dollars
respectively from the checking's and
from the savings account so to do so
they can just start a transaction there
is going to read the checking's and
savings accounts now Alice sees that
checking's in 30 in savings of 30 Caesar
the sum is 60
and so with rules $50 from the checking
account now Bob is going to do the same
he also saw that the checking's and the
savings were 30 the value and so he's
going to read all money from the savings
account whoops the invariant that the
checking in the savings account the sum
of them should be greater than zero is
now broken now the reason why this
happens is that Alice missed Bob's
updates and Bob missed Alice's update so
this execution is clearly not Sarai's
abbu but it is perfectly valid under
several week isolation guarantees in
this matters so a recent paper in the
flagship database conference Sigma 2017
actually leveraged similar types of
anomalies to break commercial
applications running under some of the
most popular e-commerce frameworks
specifically they were able to spend the
same voucher infinitely many times and
I'd like to mention they don't mention
in the paper what they did with what
they bought but in spite of these
challenges and because of the
performance concern week isolation is
popular so some of those most popular
commercial databases out there actually
offer as default a guarantee that it's
strictly weaker than series ability and
in fact the ones I'm highlighting here
don't offer Sarai's ability at all so
because of this popularity there's been
a long quest to try and formalize with
isolation guarantee and this started
very early on they started 1977 with a
seminal paper by Jim Gray who formalized
weak laced elation guarantees in terms
of locks the transactions had to acquire
before accessing shared data in 1992 the
ANSI Seahawks specification then tried
to refine those definition to allow for
non lock based implementations
unfortunately that informal definitions
they provided turned out to be ambiguous
we said to some will work by a Phil
burns and here and how Phil Byrne see
and Hal Berenson here on providing the
first formal treatment of an SI sequel
unfortunately the arm specific
definitions they provided still disallow
for certain optimistic implementations
of weak isolation which is what the work
of at whadya and Barbara Liskov
tried to address they tried to provide
the first generic specification of
isolation that would allow for more
optimistic implementations or more
aggressive implementation
now I'd like to preface something here I
think that the world why you are doing
Barbara Liskov is absolutely fantastic
so much so that had his thesis on my
bedside table for many years but in the
context of cloud storage systems I do
think that this work has some
limitations and just to highlight where
those limitations are I'm going to spend
the next couple of slide actually
highlighting what what the framework
does so at its core our gist framework
associates version order and time stamps
with a notion of a sterilization graph
so a server edition graph is a graph
where nodes represent committed
transactions and edges different
relationship between transactions so
right we - for instance denotes a
transaction t2 reading a transaction T
ones write a read write edge denotes a
transaction t2 missing t3 is right so
reading the version the proceeds a write
of t3 a write right edge denotes a
transaction t4 overwriting t3 is right
and finally a start edge - there's a
transaction on t3 committing before
transaction t5 starts isolation then
becomes defined as preventing specific
types of cycles on that graph so when
you look at Sarai's ability things are
pretty straight forward
so as ability is defined as preventing
all types of cycles and that's it when
you start looking at weekly isolation
levels however things get more complex
and illustrators quite how complex they
can get I'm just going to intuitively
motivate for more if sorry um a
definition called snapshot isolation and
I'm just going to informally specify it
ISOs natural isolation is one of the
most popular isolation guarantees out
there because it provides much of the
benefit to Sarai's ability but it allows
read operations to proceed concurrently
with write operations so informally
snapshot isolation has two requirements
first it requires the transactions read
from a committed snapshot of the system
so you can think of it as taking a
picture of the database at a given point
in time and reading from that picture
the second requirement is the concurrent
transactions should not update this
so hopefully the informal definition is
pretty a simple to understand once you
start looking it's formalization however
things get more complicated this is how
our de forma is it it prevents three
things cycles consisting of right to
right all right to eat edges cycles
consisting of right right or right to
eat edges with a single back pointing
read right edge and finally any right
right or right read edge that doesn't
also have a start edge so as you can
probably tell by the speed at which I'm
going I don't expect you to fully
understand this instead what I want you
to take out of this side is this is
fairly complex and is unlikely to allow
your tech savvy Baker to understand why
a snapshot isolation allows and normally
like writes to you for instance and the
second point I want to mention is that
if you remember I defined snapshot
isolation informally is reading from a
snapshot it's very hard to understand
the informal read from a snapshot idea
and align it to this cycle based
approach so there's a disconnect and the
problem with that disconnect is the
formalism drives what people think
so that's your definition then you're
going to think of isolation in terms of
world level construct like operation
ordering or time stamps so it shouldn't
be surprising to you that this has led
to many definitions of naturalize of
isolation they're all very in subtle
ways for instance there's no less than
eight variants of snapshot isolation and
the problem is that the ways in which
these different flavors of isolation
differ is very system specific it
depends on properties like time stamp
assignment whether the system stores a
single copy or multiple copies of every
object in the system or the number of
replicas and this matters so I'll go 18
sees one is a popular cloud-based
database out there and claims to be
searchable however the precise
definition of Sarai's ability that uses
implicitly assumes that there is a
single copy of every object in the
system as you might be guessing local
agency stores multiple copies and so
despite claiming to be Sarai's abour it
actually admits non sizable executions
and this is where the supposed
simplicity of cloud storage really comes
to bite the bread and butter of cloud
storage services is to hide these
implementations
but these implementation details today
are actually necessary to understand the
high-level semantics the weak isolation
guarantees provides you and this is
precisely the problem I think there's a
fundamental gap between how isolation
guarantees are formally defined and the
way in which they are used or understood
so on the one hand isolation guarantees
are defined in terms of low-level
construct like operation ordering of
time stands because we've seen this
logic is invisible to application and
can lead to system specific definitions
on the other applications precede the
databases of black box who say they only
get to see through the reason to execute
so this is why I believe that client
centric approach can help
like I said applications only observe
the state of the system through the
reset the execute so I'm going to do the
same I'm going to propose a model the
directly expresses isolation guarantees
in terms of what applications actually
tweet and to do so I'm going to create a
new notion of introducing a notion that
of reach States so read States
characterize the possible states in
which the storage system could have been
in based on what the transactions
actually read and then go to users
restates as part of a per transaction
commit test that is going to constraint
whether transactions observation are
consistent with a particular isolation
level now because we state summarize
what the application saw there's no
longer any need to peek inside the black
box so because we'd say so source of
inherent our model I just want to spend
a little bit of time giving you an
example of what they actually are
so let's instead of two operations a
read of Y and a read of set and let's
consider a storage system that contains
two objects y&z and the circle said they
note possible storage system States so
the read operation reads version said
one of object sent so I'm going to say
that has to Canada we states which I'm
highlighting here in red and these
corresponds to the states that contain
version said one of objects that now
it's important to highlight here is that
from the point of view of the read
operation these two states are
indistinguishable as the read operation
only sees object said it doesn't look at
object while
the bloom operation on the other hand
reads version y0 of object y so we're
going to say that it has a single
candidate we state as a single state
that contains version y 0 object y so
there's no ambiguity now using these
notions of read States and commit test
we can then define isolation guarantees
as follows a storage system guarantees a
specific isolation level I if you can
generate an execution that is a sequence
of atomic state transitions so if you
look on the slide here the arrows denote
the effect of applying a transaction to
a state and the resulting transition if
you can generate an execution that
satisfies the commit test I for every
transaction T now the challenge
obviously becomes what is the commit
test for a given isolation level so for
the purpose of this talk I'm only going
to look at Sarai's both in snapshot
isolation but we do have definitions for
all existing isolation guarantees and
proofs that they're equivalent to their
system centric counterpart so to go
ahead and define our eyes ability in
snapshot isolation I just didn't need to
define two more notions the first one is
a parent state so a parent state is a
state that precedes the state that a
transaction creates so if you could the
example here if you look at transaction
t3 the parent state of t3 will be the
state I'm highlighting here in red as is
the state that precedes the state the t3
created the next notion I need to define
is the idea of a complete state now a
complete state is a state that is a
valid reach state for all operations in
the transaction well this is intuitively
saying is that all operations in the
transaction could have read from the
same state so if you look at the example
and if you look at a transaction T that
contains two operations armed a read of
Z and a read of Y the first operation
has to read States which I'm
highlighting here in blue the second
operation has a single read state which
I'm highlighting here in red that read
state would be a complete state for T
because boy operations can read from it
so using these notions of Paris as a
complete site we can go ahead and define
Sarai's ability and snapshot isolation
so doesn't anyone have any questions
about these two definitions before I
move on yes the immediately preceding
Staters in any state they're receiving
so all right so if we look at sizeable
in your snapshot isolation now one thing
I like about this model is it makes it
fairly easier to compare and contrast
these two guarantees so if you look at
size ability Sarai's ability says that
the paris state of a transaction T
should be complete now what this is
intuitively saying is that a transaction
can read from the same state that it
commits from and so nothing happened in
between if you call the intuitive
definition of size ability which says it
should be equivalent to every
transaction executing in sequence this
is what they're saying that nothing
happened between my reading my commands
if you look at snapshot isolation then
well one thing that snapshot isolation
does is preserves the requirement that
there should be a complete state but
relaxes it to say that it can be any
state not just the parent state so you
can read from any states in the past it
also requires the concurrent
transactions should not update the same
object now if I flip back to the system
centric definition of snapshot isolation
there's a couple of points I want to
make first the definition that we rely
here completely removes the notion of a
timestamp in contrast if you look at the
system centric approach this required
the use of a start edge the second point
I want to emphasize and I hope you'll
agree with me is that if you remember I
defined snapshot isolation informally is
reading from a snapshot I hope that the
idea of a complete state Maps more
intuitively to our notion of reading
from a snapshot then the cycle based
approach that's based on read and write
operations
so this is what I find nice about this
model expressing isolation guarantees in
a client-centric way actually makes it
fairly easy to separate high level
guarantees from low level implementation
details and that makes it easier to
compare and relate different isolation
guarantees so you might remember that I
said there existed no less than 80
variants of snapshot isolation well here
they are so there's no need to worry too
much about the acronym soup on the slide
the point that matters here is that
these different flavors of isolation
differ in how they compute a snapshot so
how they're assigned time stuff now it
turns out the once you remove
implementation details like a model does
several of these isolation guarantees
that people thought two distinct
actually turn out to be equivalent and
we were able to prove that on the other
hand when these low-level implementation
details do impact high-level semantics
our model is still sufficiently
expressive to capture their differences
and so we're able to use these two
features to systematize snapshot
isolation variance and derive the first
clean hierarchy of these guarantees so
if you identify the right abstraction it
should have some semantic benefits and
hopefully what I've just done is to try
and convince you that there is so amount
of semantic benefit that can be gained
by expressing isolation in a
client-centric way but I would argue
that the right abstraction should have
some performance benefit as well and
this is what I'm going to try and
convince you of next that a client
centric approach to system design can
actually be the key to enabling good
performance so before I move on does
anyone have any questions about the
isolation framework
all right so the reason for I believe
that a client centric approach can bring
better performance is the following a
concentric approach to enforcing
correctness actually brings more
flexibility to implementations because
it allows implementations to cheat so
occur if a system centric way of
defining correctness requires that every
component of the data store implement a
particular correctness guarantee for
whatever definition of correctness you
might want
in contrast a client centric definition
only requires applications observe a
correct datastore or stated is
indistinguishable from a correct
datastore
so if apply this idea a couple of times
over the course of my PhD but the one I
want to focus on here because I think is
the most interesting to me is this ideas
application to security so the rest of
this talk is very much going to still be
about client centric approach to
transactional processing but the domain
is going to be slightly different so
there's going to be a slight change of
pace just to warn you so in a nutshell
allowing the system to cheat is what
allowed us to design the first system to
support arm oblivious sizable
transactions and what I mean by that is
to design a cloud-based datastore that
supports ERISA both transactions were
also hiding from the cloud access
patterns and what I mean by access
patterns are hiding what data is being
accessed so what objects when that data
is being accessed or how frequently and
how that data is being accessed so
whether it's a read or write operation
and the sort of core idea that allowed
us to do that was the following
traditional definitions of Sarai's
ability state the Sarai's ability should
only apply when a transaction commits it
only holds for committed transactions we
reformulated that in a client centric
way to say the Sarai's ability should
only be enforced when clients observe
that a transaction has committed because
that's the only time where they get to
see that a transaction has committed and
what I'm going to do in the rest of this
talk is try to explain how this
reformulation of Sarai's ability is what
allowed us to support concurrent sizable
transactions
is what allowed us to guarantee
durability specifically how to preserve
the effects of transactions across
faders and finally is also what allowed
us to amortize the overheads of
guaranteeing obliviousness across many
concurrent requests but before I begin I
just want to briefly motivate why this
is a useful problem to tackle in the
first place and why you might want to
hide access patterns and the reason for
why you might want to hide access
patterns is that our application store
sensitive information and so moving that
information to the cloud means in the
app you're now trusting an untrusted
third party with things like Social
Security numbers or arm health
information now the obvious way to slice
said this is to use encryption and most
cloud storage systems do provide a form
of encryption at rest but encryption is
often not sufficient the very fact that
an ecologist is accessing a particular
record may reveal that a patient has
cancer
well the frequency at which that record
is being accessed may review above the
type and the severity of the cancer and
this is because chemotherapy
appointments actually have a very
specific schedule to them that is very
unique to specific cancer types and
specific stages of cancer so in order to
protect sensitive information
it is a least desirable to hide metadata
about how you're accessing the the
records not just the content of the
records and we're going to do that in a
set up the mirrors are the cloud storage
black box approach that I've been
talking about and we're going to call
this the trusted proxy model so why the
name says this model assumes a trust of
centralized proxy through which clients
communicate with an untrusted cloud
storage so you can think of it as a set
of doctors are talking to a server on
the hospital local area network but
storing data on a service like Amazon or
Azure over the white area now we're also
going to make the more realistic
assumption and we're going to extend
prior work in doing so that arm clients
and the clients in the proxy can feel
whether the cloud storage is reliable so
you can think of it as a doctor tripping
over the power cord of the servers of
the hospital's basement but having many
smart engineers provide the abstraction
of reliable cloud storage
and the system that we're going to
design oh bloody is going to mein
oblivious been maintained obliviousness
by religiously maintaining one invariant
that of workload independence and what
what good independence says is that the
request pattern sent to the untrusted
cloud must remain completely independent
of the workload or of any concurrently
executing transactions and what this
does is that the cloud storage will
learn never learn any information about
the request simply by observing the
reason why they're being executed on the
cloud because there's no correlation
between those requests and the actual
workload so the challenge becomes how
can we guarantee workload independence
in the presence of transactions so any
nests out of that cool transactions are
basically a bunch of reading rights so
we're going to take as a starting point
of protocol the guarantees workload
independence and height access patterns
through reads and writes
and that's oblivious tram or aura and at
its core the way that Aram ensures work
out independence is basically by making
all requests to cloud storage look
completely random so because they're
random or they appear random they're
completely independent of the workload
now there's been a large body of work on
om constructions and I don't claim to be
able to summarize them all here but I
just want to give you the intuition so
how they guarantee worked at
Independence so ad they're very at the
very highest level of attraction an
orang construction takes logical read
and write operations so the ones that
the client executes and generates a set
of physical reason writes to cloud
storage so that the physical location of
objects on the cloud remains hidden so
to achieve this the proxy is going to
hide requests for real data or more
requests for dummy data as the data is
encrypted the cloud storage cannot
distinguish which requester for real
data in which requests are for dummy
data and consequently learns no
information about the requests now
obviously this is at the very highest
level abstraction and that there's many
many much research in the subtleties of
guaranteeing world code independence
given this broad context but hopefully
these give you an inter
and at the very highest level of
abstraction this is sufficient to
guarantee workload independence for
reads and writes but when you start
looking at transactions however there's
several new challenges that emerge the
first one was how do you guarantee
isolation if you're trying to execute
concurrent transactions specifically how
do you do concurrency control the second
challenge is how do you guarantee
durability and the specific problem here
is that durability requires a very
specific ordering of rights for for
consistency while the ORM requires an
equally specific but different ordering
of rights for security and finally how
do you guarantee good performance when
most around constructions afford only
limited concurrency so like I've hinted
at the start of my talk we're going to
answer these questions by relying on the
simple principle that have delayed
visibility now delay visibility embraces
the client centric approach I've been
advocating it recognizes that Sarah's
ability guarantees must only be enforced
when a client observes that a
transaction has committed but makes the
additional observation that commit
operations can be delayed and we're
going to use this observation to
partition the system into fixed time
fixed size epochs and delay commit
notifications until the end of the epoch
until the end of each epoch now because
the rise ability must only be enforced
for transactions of the client Caesars
committed delaying commit notifications
until the end of the epoch Misa we're
only required to enforce consistency and
durability that epoch boundaries only
because epoch boundaries are the only
point at which a client will get to see
that his transaction is committed now
because we can arm because we're only
enforcing consistency at epoch
boundaries rights don't have to mean a
durable until the end of the epoch and
this actually allows us to execute
transactions add the trusted proxy which
is not reliable and buffer intermediate
versions of each right in a version
cache until the end of the epoch again
we can do that because the only point at
which we have to guarantee durability is
boundaries now this approach actually
has two benefits that help improve
performance first is going to reduce a
number of requests that we have to send
to the aura and this is because as we
only guarantee durability at epoch
boundaries it is sufficient to write the
last version of every key only to cloud
storage and skip all the intermediate
versions so if you look at the example
you have two versions of either V
written in a version cache over the
course of an epoch it is sufficient to
write the last version of the only
skipping the red version because that
red version does not need to be made
durable the second benefit that comes
from buffering intermediate writes is
the ability to implement a multi version
sizable concurrency control on top of a
single version Ora and for those of you
unfamiliar with this multi-version
concurrency control allows read-only
transact read operations to proceed
concavity of write operations and so
this allows us to significantly speed-up
read-only transactions and for those if
you're interested we chose an algorithm
called multi version timestamp ordering
and all of the doctors that will every
Rossi
yes which has some scalability problems
as you are hinting at distributing the
proxy actually introduces two challenges
one is obviously you have to do
distributed transactions but that can be
done relatively efficiently the main
challenge is that the communication
between those two copies of the proxy
needs to be oblivious as well and so if
the network is untrusted between the two
proxy that's actually an open question
if the network is trusted the proxy
could be decentralized relatively
efficiently so the choice of concurrency
control is actually quite important we
want to ensure the Delaine commit
notifications there's not increased
contention likewise we want to ensure
that transactions within the same epoch
can actually see each other's effects
for instance we want the read of the
dark blue transaction to see the effect
of the read transaction the right of the
read transaction
so to enable this we actually chose a
concurrency control that optimistically
exposes uncommitted rights and abort sir
eyes ability violation at commit time
and again the reason why we can do this
is because um we only need to guarantee
consistency at epoch boundaries only and
that's why we chose a multi version time
stamp ordering so this is all I'm going
to say from the performance side what
did I like about epochs and delay
visibility is that while epochs improve
performance through increasing
flexibility it is the rigid and
deterministic structure of epoch that
actually helps your body guarantee
workload independence so the system is
such the the cloud storage will always
see the same sequence of read operations
followed by a set of buffered writes
adding padding if necessary to keep the
epoxides constant and so there's no
correlation between what arm the system
the clients are actually executing and
the same the number of reads and the
frequency of reads and writes that the
storage system will see now these winds
and writes then eventually have to be
executed by the author and the challenge
here is that around constructions afford
only limited concurrency whereas the
nature of the applications that we
target require sustaining a high load of
concurrent requests so we must somehow
paralyze the construction and there's
two challenges here the first one is
that we obviously want our paralyzation
to remain correct specifically we want
our construction to be linearizable and
what I mean by linearizable is that the
sequence of reason wise that we execute
in the parallel construction should
return the same values they would have
done in the sequential implementation
the second requirement is that we want
our paralyzation to be secure so you're
in our paralyzation to rain workload
independence and understand why this is
actually quite challenging let me just
remind you that a no Ram implementation
takes a logical operation and generates
a set of physical reads and writes to
cross storage so the some operations
access real data and others access dummy
data now in general linearize ability
says that we can execute non conflicting
operations concurrently but requires
that operations that exhibit data
dependencies
we executed sequentially for instance
the rights of the red object here should
wait for the read of that same red
object to finish now it turns out the
waiting for these data depends is to be
satisfied actually introduces timing
channels the read write must wait for
the red weed to finish but does not need
to wait for the dummy read to finish so
the cloud storage could um users
difference in behavior to infer the
position of real blocks by selectively
delaying weeds and observing where the
rights are correspondingly delayed so
the obvious way to address this issue is
to wait for all potential data
dependencies to be satisfied before
executing it right unfortunately any
block can contain real data and so they
can exist any potential to tip the data
dependencies between any pairs of reads
and writes the long story short is there
is never secure to execute reason writes
in parallel so we did this as 11 and may
lemonade
we again leverage the flexibility
provided by delayed visibility to delay
cost storage rights until the end of the
epoch now we can do this because again
the Oh RAM only needs to be consistent
durable at epoch boundaries so it's
perfectly okay to delay the class
storage rights until the end of the
epoch now the language in this way
allows us to partition the rme into a
read phase in a write phase where always
are executed in parallel and all rights
are executed in parallel what this does
is impose a fixed structure between all
weeds and all rights that obscures all
the data dependencies it still allows
for high concurrency though because all
the reads are executed in parallel and
all the rights are executed in parallel
which is the goal that we set out to
accomplish so this is what we're now
going to say about oh bloody about sorry
about this particular implementation I'm
going to just mention that we do have a
formal proof of security and that we
were able to guarantee durability in the
presence of proxy failures but I
wouldn't discuss it in this talk and so
what I'll do is move on to the
evaluation and ask the question what is
the cost of guaranteeing obliviousness
and to answer this question we looked at
three applications TP
in small bag which are to standard
transaction processing benchmarks the
simulator off roughly am shopping card
application in a small banking
application and free health which is a
port of a rel real French a medical
record application and we value the
system against two baselines no proof
which is a system that shares the same
concurrency control logic of your body
but no e box and my secret I know DB
which is a multi version sizable
database and we are implemented a 70
second latency between the proxy in the
cloud storage as this is latency that I
see when I access a ec2 from Ithaca so
the first point I want to look at is
throughputs now if we look at throughput
for the three applications and
transactions per second and here hi oh
is better what we see is that throughput
arm is oh bloody stupid is reasonable it
suffers from a 5 to 7 X 5 to 9 X sorry
throughput drop on the to contention
bottleneck free health and TPCC
applications and up to 12 X lower
throughput on the resource bottlenecks
small back applications now obviously
this is still a significant performance
slowdown so I just want to give a little
bit more context small Bank area has
sustained throughput of 2000
transactions per second so if your
gloves half-full kind of person this is
above the same order of magnitude as the
visa processing systems average
throughput which is about 2000
transactions per second if you're a
glass half empty kind of person this is
still a long ways away from the visa
processing systems peak throughput which
is 56,000 transactions per second the
point I want to emphasize here though is
that the reason why we're able to
achieve even close to reasonable
throughput is because delayed visibility
is what allows us to both paralyze the
construction and amortize the cost of
executing requests or AM request over
many concurrent requests so without
delay visibility the Roth report that we
were able to achieve with six
transactions per second
now obviously this comes at a cost
namely if you a partitioning system into
epochs you're going to increase latency
so if we look at the latency numbers in
milliseconds for the three applications
and here lowers better we see a 70 X
increase in latency for TPCC and if
small of 17 to 20 X increase for free
health and small Bank and this is
because yeah sorry what is what is the
absolute and you delays yeah having of
the epoch so there you see in this world
countries that had the you're seeing
uh-oh sorry this was a bit so the
latency the average latency 50 PCC is in
the hundreds of milliseconds here so the
cost of executed epoch is about 314
millisecond is that correlate and you
have a parameter you controlling the
system which is equals yes how are you
choosing that parameter if you wait for
the next slide sorry no question the
reason why TPCC suffers from a higher
latency than the other two applications
is because the epoch it has many more
rights than the other two applications
and as a result we need to configure a
large epoch size which is more costly
but to answer your question if we now
look at the graph that has the arm
Epoque size in millisecond and the
resulting throughput for a fixed number
of clients what you see is two things
Annie pole that is too short causes
transactions to repeatedly abort which
kills throughput what epod that is too
long
causes unnecessary idle time causing
throughput to taper off to the right
side of the graph so for instance if you
look at small Bank small Bank is going
to increase very sharply until about 50
millisecond and the reason for why that
is is this transactions of small Bank
are pretty much all identical or they
have similar size so either all
transactions can commit or non-kin
should occur TPCC however which is the
the blue oh sorry the red line on the
graph TPCC is transactions that come in
all shapes and sizes and so the shorter
transactions start being able to commit
first before the longer ones which is
why the increase is my softer if you
adjusted epoxides based on queries or
the load so what we do is to fix an
epoch size and leak the information of
an epoch size now this has two impacts
one you're right
that it might allow you to distinguish
whether you're running a free a medical
application or a ecommerce application
what it does not reveal is what current
queries all are actually running and
whether what particular medical record
they're accessing face because it's
fixed but you are completely right that
if you want your system to perform well
you want an epoch size that that mod
models your workload we explicitly did
not investigate the possibility of
tuning the epoxides adaptively
we fix it and this models the system if
you were willing to leak more
information like you have a diurnal
pattern where at night you have more
work fewer queries and the day you could
imagine tuning the epoxides that way but
you're right that this leaks more
information so this is I'm going to say
about a body but hopefully this has
given you intuition for how the idea of
delay visibility is sort of the secret
sauce that allowed us to provide even
close to reasonable overhead and the
process what I've tried to do is explain
how this idea is what allowed us to
extend the arm abstraction to support
parallel accesses now ask you to trust
me there's also what allowed us to
extend your abstraction to tolerate
failures and more generally I hope this
talk is giving you intuition for how a
client centric approach to system design
does provide some semantic benefit and
can be the key to enable better system
implementations so in the next you know
few minutes I just want to spend a
little bit of time highlighting what I
would like to do next so as it's
probably quite clear from this talk I'm
interested in issues of consistency and
transaction processing and I'm very much
interested in basing myself on my core
interest but looking in new applications
and specifically there's three things
I'm interested in looking at first I'd
like to investigate broader notions of
application centric correctness broad
notions of correctness that are emerging
in
in some new applications like
collaborative applications or numerical
applications second I'm interested in
continuing to look at how to bring
oblivious transsexual processing closer
to practicality as you've seen there's
still a long ways to go but in terms of
decentralizing the proxy in terms of
reducing the overheads further and
finally I'm more just I'm more broadly
interested of in ideas of transaction
processing while minimizing trust so
just to give you a flavor what I'm
talking about I just want to highlight
three specific ideas in each of these
categories so one specific idea
applications I'm interested in looking
at is um numerical application so these
are the applications that underpin and
many machine learning algorithms now
there's been a large body of work on
distributed systems on a weak
consistency where a particular object is
going to be consistent within a specific
error bound or specific time bound or
specific ordering of rights now this is
always been controversial because it's
fairly hard to reason about the eight
and eighty-seven percent probability
that you did buy your ticket in Seattle
for your Microsoft interview but in the
context of where machine learning
however there's two things that are
promising the first one is the eventual
consistency always talked about the
Inquirer sent when updates stopped now
in a commercial application or in
e-commerce application updates never
really stopped but in a machine learning
system there is a point at which updates
are likely to stop is when you've
trained the model the second point is
that there's actually been a large body
of work a large body of theoretical work
demonstrates the machine learning
algorithms like stochastic gradient
descent are actually quite good at
tolerating some amount of asynchrony and
you can actually define fairly strong
theoretical bounds on what it takes to
have them converge so what I'm
interested in looking at is whether or
not we can leverage the theory behind we
consistency in many of the algorithms
being designed in that context to design
parameter servers that can be weakly
consistent and speed up model training
the second area that I want to look at
is to continue bringing transaction
private transaction processing closer to
practicality and one of the biggest
hurdles there is that the overheads of
most oblivia systems
my system included grows as a function
of data size now in the way that I
defined our databases I've assumed that
they look like a sequence of keys and a
sequence of values and there's a mapping
between the two that's kind of what a
database looks like but they're
alternative ways to build fast database
systems one of which is by using a log
or you have a vast of a very fast shared
log the transaction that users update
and the way to recompute the state is to
replay the updates it turns out that
because you were playing the updates log
structured databases are already
oblivious the problem is that the client
playback of replaying the updates
becomes a bottleneck so what I'm
interested in looking at this can we
alleviate that bottleneck in a way that
they're still oblivious and is that an
easier problem than providing oblivious
across the data size in the last problem
I'm interested in looking at is how can
you execute a scalable shared
computation between untrusted parties so
I would argue that we already know how
to build the storage for trusted
scalable computation it's called a
database and the unknowing abstraction
that allows these systems to scale is
that they provide a partially ordered
set of operations where conflicting
operations are ordered but non
conflicting operations are not and what
this allows us to do is to execute non
conflicting operations on disjoints
charts and scale the system horizontally
in that way we also know how to execute
shared computation between untrusted
third parties let's call Byzantine fault
tolerance unfortunately the abstraction
that is provided by business a fault
tolerant system is that of a totally
ordered log where every operation must
be processed by every replica so there's
horizontal scalability but there's
absolutely no vertical scalability
horizontal scale base sorry
so my question is how can we combine the
two how can we build a system a
Byzantine fault-tolerant system that
provides this abstraction of a partially
ordered set of transactions so that so
the flashy question is how do you do
two-phase commit when you don't trust
the person running the two-phase commit
so with that I'd like to acknowledge
that this is the work of many
collaborators and I somewhere in this
room and I'll be happy to take any
questions thank you very much where they
had a similar insight which is actually
you're providing guarantees to the
observer of the state and you can do
batching and depend to monitoring to
make things appear to be synchronous
even if in the implementation they're
actually in synchronous so how would you
compare you know that work with the work
that you've done I think they're very
very the spirit is the same so in the
Blizzard work one of the challenges as
you have to keep metadata around to
further user to know and to track
dependencies in the oh bloody work
because you're fixing the output for
everyone you don't have to worry about
the metadata tracking that's the sort of
the big difference the we have some work
in causal consistency where we end up
doing something that is almost identical
to Blizzard in the context of more
efficient implementations of course of
consistency where we have to track more
meta data at the client but the benefit
that we get is the updates become less
depend on each other and we're less
likely to career slowdown cascades of
shards falling the the big thing about
oh bloody versus the blizzard is that we
don't have to keep additional metadata
because we're fixing the output commit
for everyone was I think it was that you
can people become visible a good repair
you know this was whatever it's not like
two girls yeah okay if I'm using the
wrong name we're thinking about the same
paper at least think for this particular
approach the metadata and how you can
compress the metadata data and track
dependencies is what becomes challenging
so in the case of file system you have
to keep track of interrupts and things
like that
at a low granularity than what we had to
keep track on and so is that are you
taking advantage of the ability to roll
our you know roll up program forward
realize that okay if rolled forward on
correct assumptions and then in the rare
case that it's incorrect sir roll back
or can you imagine taking advantage of
speculation so in the context of the arm
oh bloody work we speculate by exposing
uncommitted rights early as opposed to
before they have committed which can
cause a series of cascading aborts at
the Grand Avenue POC within an epoch the
in the course of consistency what I
haven't discussed we take advantage of
speculation in that I may be able to see
a value say of why and when I try to
access X the value of x that should have
been the causally consistent value is
not there I wish might have to wait but
in both cases we kind of leverage the
ability it's not quite speculation but
it's the ability to aggressively move
forward in a way that we don't otherwise
dealing with transactions as your unit
of execution makes all this a lot
cleaner and easier
it doesn't reduce challenges when you
look at opacity so one thing that we did
not look at is opacity which actually
places constraints on currently
executing transactions I like I like
about the general experience of
archeology from it very much inside and
only early part fun day on their body
part I like a very very simple practical
question if you want ready if I were to
take my sequel 5 7 put in your proxy and
just keep shipping the encrypted logs in
the back and once in a while I think
that a database a backup of the Internet
of is and just shoved in the storage how
far a performance will be local my
suppose will be as well as my seat all
right how what why I wanted problems you
see with money just taking your proxy
approach you just like making it as
silly as simply running my Siebel and
sending out the encrypted loss so the
big problem comes from the amount of
information that you're having to
transfer at every time so two things one
um because you can't reveal how many
operations have changed how many date
how much data has changed every time you
compute a backup you would actually have
to compute the backup locally entirely
and ship it so there's no mechanism
we're doing def because the differed
leak information about the size of how
many operations of change now if you're
happy to pay the end cost of periodic
backups
you're still assuming that or the
information can store can be can be held
exclusively at the proxy so in our
system what we do we we leverage caching
and we leverage the fact that a subset
of the data can actually be stored
locally but we don't make the assumption
that everything can be stored locally
cuz I think in the scenario that you're
describing you do make that assumption
hold on follow how you practice how
often that assumption is not valid like
what it might do transactions um how
many use cases we have where I need a
petabyte of transactional store and how
many times is a transactional store is
like whatever 10 terabyte they are like
the ones your life or the last ring um
okay
these ones they like I think it's
obviously worth mentioning the
state-of-the-art wear and understanding
the space better like I appreciate all
that I'm saying if I take a really
natural very very practical take on it
you know how much this is already needy
there are how much of this is like you
know we got anything in a few years one
thing that I completely would like to do
is to remove this proxy so that
everything can be placed directly in the
cloud storage so getting rid of the
centralized proxy in a way that can be
placed directly on the cloud so that the
hospital doesn't have to manage a a
proxy is completely the logical way
forward to answer your question is it
for in terms of currently it depends on
how much money you're willing to invest
in the cost of the server so in the
context of medical records for instance
from the medical image we can actually
be quite large so if you have a machine
that has to store the MRI of people the
those particular images actually grow
quite quickly um so that can be one case
where you do actually quickly get to
sort of not necessary that many objects
but where the objects can be quite large
but you're right that in many cases the
arm you can assume that the storage will
local storage is enough what we found is
that when we looking at all of the IT
space medical mighty space people
offload data to cloud storage and also
much for scalability but for fault
tolerance at which point the logging
solution that you were describing
becomes interesting but dipping the log
for checkpointing is not something that
we were able to find out how to do
efficiently yet
so I'm your second piece of you to work
deserve consistency for perimeter it's a
motorcycle um so then I think that's
really interesting because the
consistency of parameters over time
changes so you know very early on it
makes sense to provide like really
strong consistency guarantees because
you're certain not sure where you're
learning is gonna go but then over time
you wonder if you can relax them a
little bit more and then end up with the
equivalent accuracy for the resulting
model so have you thought about how an
application could express those
consistency guarantees to a started
system you know you deal in the world of
formalism so what would an interface to
such a a sort of system actually look
like and since its feature work it's
fine you don't have like concrete answer
but having thought about it you know so
what we what I was currently thinking
about is leveraging some of the work
that's been done by you and Vader on
continuous consistency models where you
describe consistency as a unit that has
three axes one is staleness the other
one is ordering and one is the weights
of how asic the weights of writes
they've already happened so how how many
ways can you have diverse by so and this
provides us your three axes space now in
terms of how you could express
consistency is like changing over time I
think as long as you're willing to have
a notion of you could imagine
sort of SLES what isolates but
constraints that say if iteration is
greater than 77 I want my cone it to be
this otherwise that how you would
enforce this because you now need to
treat a track of iterations or you know
time like this I don't know but I can
imagine having basically a small sort of
you know a set of small statements that
say if this then this conet if that then
did you know sort of classifies and
update as being urgent they have
sometimes worth right and the the sense
of urgency changes depending on so you
can have sort of like content specific
rules as well now that kind of thing
it's away from basic it's not so much
about versions and ordering as much as
distance anyway I think that's an
interesting there's been some work on
actually tracking inconsistency in
machine learning algorithms using
dependency cycles much like the ones by
the idea that I was talking about and
you know if you have a cycle that means
you're more like you'd have any
consistency in tracking error that way
so I think that's all that might also be
a way to access you know this is there's
work from marketing Morales on elastic
machine learning where the assumption
was if I lose a nose oh well it's just a
different sample of the data I'm running
with for this iteration right then and
it turns out they converge super well in
practice hard to prove things about it
but like in practice they were very very
strong result so in your setting you can
also do it in terms of saying you know I
figure out what are the dependencies and
if any the only way for me to actually
move forward is to ignore what a
transaction this is uncomfortable for me
consistency wise you can just drop it on
the ground and and very often in machine
learning model is gonna chug along and
an in conversion in X and X wrong so I
think there's a huge potential on that
space there's this amount of semantic
information that can be leveraged in
specific types of machine learning like
publicity grab models we can actually
encode using no let domain experts that
we might never interact and therefore
there's no edge between us but there
might be an edge between me and I know
Dan Irene or something or between
someone else my advisor and that also
can be something where it might make it
more sense to produce an update there
because there's no dependency
Oh
[Applause]
you